>> FROM THE CREATORS OF "JERSEY
SHORE," MTV'S HOT NEW SHOW,
"FLORIBAMA SHORE" BRINGS THE
PARTY TO THE GULF COAST.
THE COEDS ARE HOT.
THE PARTIES ARE JUMPING AND IT
WAS ALL FILMED IN THE MIDDLE OF
HURRICANE IRMA.
>> MY NAME IS KYLER AND I'M A
PIECE OF [ BLEEP ].
>> MY MAMA DIDN'T RAISE ME TO BE
AFRAID OF NO STORM.
SHE RAISED ME TO BE A FEARLESS
CHRISTIAN SEX ADDICT WITH GUM
DISEASES YOU AIN'T EVEN HEARD
OF, PLAYER.
>> SUP, YA'LL, MY NAME IS
PONTOON.
AND I USED
TO CARRY AROUND MY DAD'S ASHES
UNTIL I LET GO OF THEM ON A
ROLLER COASTER.
>> MY NAME'S EPCOT.
I WAS BORN IN THE CHINESE PART
OF EPCOT CENTER.
MY FAVORITE FOOD IS GUM.
>> OKAY, WAIT A MINUTE, THERE IS
HURRICANE COMING.
WE NEED TO GO, Y'ALL.
>> WHAT'S UP, WIENERS!
MY NAME IS COURTNEY WITH A
COURT.
>> A PARTY IS BREWING DOWN
SOUTH, Y'ALL, AND THERE'S A 90%
CHANCE OF DRAMA.
>> HURRICANES FOR THE HURRICANE,
Y'ALL.
>> HURRICANE?
HER A BITCH.
>> YOU BEEN GETTING ON MY DAMN
NERVES EVER SINCE WE GOT TO THIS
HOUSE.
>> YOU CAN'T TALK TO ME LIKE
THAT.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING DO ABOUT
IT, CRY TO YOUR DADDY?
>> YOU DON'T KNOW MY DADDY.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW MY DADDY!
>> MY DAD'S HULK HOGAN!
♪♪♪
>> HOGAN SISTERS REUNITED.
HAVE YOU EVER MET HIM?
>> NO, I WANT TO THOUGH.
>> AT THIS POINT, SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY IN THE HOUSE IS
COUPLED UP.
TRISHA IS WITH KYLER.
EPCOT IS WITH KYLER.
AND COURTNEY I BELIEVE IS WITH
KYLER.
JUSTIN IS FREAKING OUT BECAUSE
HIS WIFE'S NOT ANSWERING THE
PHONE.
>> SARAH, CALL ME.
>> BUT I'M NOT WORRIED, YA'LL,
BECAUSE TRISH SAID SHE WOULD
BANG ME AFTER KYLER.
>> DESPITE EVERYTHING, THIS
HOUSE IS ALL ABOUT THE LOVE.
>> GUYS, I THINK STAYING HERE
THROUGH THE HURRICANE WAS THE
BEST DECISION WE EVER MADE.
>> YEAH.
OTHERWISE I WOULD HAVE NEVER MET
MY LONG LOST SISTER.
>> OR FALLEN IN LOVE.
Y'ALL, THIS HURRICANE'S TAUGHT
ME SOMETHING IMPORTANT.
WHEN YOU FIND SOMEONE YOU LOVE,
NEVER LET THEM GO.
TRISH, WILL YOU MARRY ME?
>> HELP ME!
>> JUST BREATHE MAN, JUST
BREATHE.
>> I NEVER HAD
PRE-MARITAL SEX.
>> "FLORIBAMA SHORE."
WHY DO YOU MAKE US DO THIS?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪